guys Lisa doesn't know what honest
trailers are hey it's Greg out here
thanks for outing me like that it's Lisa
mihalick Lisa mihalick she has a YouTube
channel guys make sure to follow her
she's uploading regularly on it it's
good stuff I've seen the commercial that
plays before her video it's really good
come on look at her take her in not
telling you don't want to see this face
and personality of one video without
this face at least one just check out
why Lisa does not know what honest
trailers are I don't I'm being honest
with you I don't stop okay all this
trailers it's from a channel called
screen junkies but what they do on there
honest trailers is they spoof an entire
movie in a matter of a few minutes in
trailer for me cool yeah today's patient
the day shop gonna go out to Matt beer
it's December 6th right now we still
don't have access to the channel no idea
when this video is up but you're
watching it now
[Music]
responsible for all things cuz the field
as children's who imagine what if Santa
was real hey what if he was a legally
binding curse inflicted on whoever stole
the pants off Santa's dead body
this movie is why a whole generation
can't spell its name huh return to the
Christmas of 90s past where just like a
pop star making a happy Christmas album
really are no wires at the height of
their powers would pump out a half a
Christmas movie that you think is a
Class A because you were a kid when it
came out he's fighting his jerk ex-wife
and her turkey bread over custody of
their jerk his job give it his own jerk
Claire you want this doll or not about
this link get back shaken by his jerk
co-workers then lose his career clean
legal record and son in the process
happy experience Oh about the magic of
Christmas that sucks all the magic out
of Christmas Santa isn't a man but a job
title say to die so often the rules of
succession of ended on his business card
and say there's a given a choice put a
virus to twist the host by understand
she's mask from which there is no escape
woman or a child or a dog I'm
they made a movie out of that - wolf did
they believe again specifically we
believe that therapies for losers
psychiatrists as this broken family
drama makes it clear we don't fix he's
not Santa
we're not only is all mental health
advice stupid but the whole reason the
hero believes in Santa is to get revenge
on his ex-wife well Neal's head comes to
a point go ahead dr. Ellen I guess we
know who is the teacher's pet Wow with
its own paramilitary squad it operates
outside of human law we're worst
nightmare eternal child brides trained
to service Santa's every day look pretty
good for your age
aunt bernarde a cruel taskmaster who
keeps the workers toiling away their
stations excuse me are we on a coffee
break and what they're saying is old
life behind
or else Christmas is dead for everyone
responsible for killing the spirit of
Christmas
would you there is no way this place as
a union so revisit this nineties
throwback that makes everyone's
fantasies come true from kids fantasies
that Santa is real parents fantasies
that their children will respect them
the studio's fantasies that this movie
deserved a trilogy and Tim Allen's
fantasy that he wouldn't immediately
crack in a police interrogation name you
know
actually happened look it up I was
arrested
why story right styles the kids that
make your iPhones they can't all be JT t
true romance the set occurs
I get what they mean by honest now the
closer the best character on the show
Wow
just like Billy got real there yeah
that's their job they rip they they
nitpick and you rip apart a movie in
trailer format I feel maybe ELISA
shouldn't watch anymore right should I
view the movie they said some pretty
strong things like therapists are laying
there pointing out things of what they
of how the movie can actually perceive
this movie is a family drama it's a
story about a man who gets after killing
Santa gets forced into a position to
sacrifice his whole regular life to
become Santa loses his family in the
process lose his job
essentially loses his health because he
gains a lot of weight it's really about
a man deteriorating into Santa Claus
total force yeah that's pretty funny
stuff it's I've never viewed it that way
I haven't seen this movie in maybe like
eight years or something like that or
seven every single time I think of it
I'm like no he wanted that his hair just
kept you tried shaving it yeah and even
when and it's true everyone in this
movie is proud of a jerk to each other
I mean yeah that's that was intense to
just like everyone just staring at him
that's really I think for the time that
came out it's just nowhere near as
offensive yeah in a day and age wearing
pant fat shame I feel like so many
people go to therapy and psychiatry now
it's such an accepted norm yeah at least
in California so definitely I don't
really know what other parts of America
but I feel like California it's a very
California yeah and like everyone being
a juror people notice that more in
movies now is I'm just the humerus that
the Santa Claus movie has but that's
part of his arc is that he's a jerk and
then he grows into being the real Santa
he's that's supposed to be the good
thing that's supposed to be the good
thing yeah there would you be Santa
Claus no you wouldn't
I love Santa Claus and like what he
brings to the world but I could not do
it do you believe in Santa I of course I
believe I believe in the spirit of Santa
Claus do you believe in the actual
physical manifestation of Santa Claus
delivering presents I get some that say
from Santa I want what you are answering
non-direct
you need to tell me directly do you
believe in Senate no no I believe Jesus
comes to everyone's chimney beautiful
shoots down their beautiful skinny
Christ and gives us all it's beautiful
to Body of Christ
yeah yeah bread mm-hmm well that's what
Christmas is all about
literally Jesus is the reason for the
season I heard Christmas was a pagan
holiday I have not heard that
Christmas is a pagan holiday on the
Google search but I've also heard pagan
is not satanic I don't know enough to
contribute then why are you here today
you be Santa yeah you would oh you just
said I don't believe in him but if he
was real of a totally killer go to every
single house once a year the rest of the
day of the year getting fat and sleep
tomorrow I can sleep have my little
slaves or Oh elves Wow do my Santa I
think what he does is wonderful but
putting a bunch of little people in
charge house yeah little people
elves are those different it just sounds
better yes yeah they're they're very
different
tomatoe tomorrow before we wrap up this
video guys patron of the day shout out
for a man named Matthew beer that beer
he's one of our highest pledges on
patreon and he is a super friendly guy
also very weird we do Google Hangouts
with some patrons I'm pretty sure he's
gonna be a serial killer one of these
days he kind of just has this like calm
way he has like one quick liners and
very brief answers yes well it's just
the way he carries himself don't get me
wrong as long as he's a high pledge
patron even if he can people totally
cool it as long as he's still on patreon
even if it's just like a dollar or
lowest pledged that's cool if you get
rid of your pledge on patreon I will
turn you in to the police with actual no
evidence to support my accusation
whatsoever but I will get you arrested
this is not a threat but a warning which
is a threat in some ways you're being
threatened Matt I'd still consider no
it's seriously Matt right now I mean we
explained we explained the the whole
issue on patreon and you know Matt's
just a hard-working guy like the rest of
us Americans out there out of nowhere he
like doubled his pledge for us I'm not
gonna give the actual number because
that would be messed up I just want to
say like we took notice of that dude and
we didn't ask you to do that and
if you ever want to lower your pledge
feel free to do that we really
appreciate the support you're giving us
while we were currently dealing with
harsh times so in a way you're our Santa
Claus oh that was beautiful baby thanks
Matt
that was beautiful no Santa Claus we'll
call it Santa killer oh wow
subscribe to the real rejects people
click that notification bell to get
notified every time one of our videos is
up also Lisa bellick mihalick lisa
McCulloch Lisa Mellie is on YouTube now
people she has a channel with actual
videos on it they are not modeling
videos despite your disappointment why
haven't you done modeling videos why
would I you how was your channel doing I
didn't watch your latest video you know
what we'll do I'm gonna do a reaction on
one of your videos on patreon patreon
and I'll heavily criticize it no thank
you won't be able to see it unless
you've pledged to our patreon don't
worry I have no idea if I'm gonna
criticize it I'll give it my all
I'm gonna have their stuff to criticize
there's every not just woman but people
just talk to me in this town I
understand nothing but generous